No: 139,788.
The announcement of the Fife result made it a mathematical certainty.
The naysayers had won the day.
Scotland voted against independence by a small majority.
Amid relief and happiness for "No" voters,...
...those in charge of the "Yes" campaign were forced to accept defeat.
Scotland has by majority decided not,...
...at this stage, to become an independent country.
I accept that verdict of the people and I call on all of Scotland to follow suit.
It was a win for Alistair Darling's "Better Together" campaign...
We have chosen unity over division...
...and positive change rather than needless separation.
...but also a win for democracy.
Turnout was high, very high, across the board.
The turnout is 87.9 percent.
Prime Minister David Cameron campaigned heavily to keep the United Kingdom together,...
...but he was pragmatic once the results were in.
While delighted that Scotland voted no, he also promised new powers for Scotland.
To all of those who did vote for independence, we hear you.
We now have a chance, a great opportunity,...
...to change the way the British people are governed and change it for the better.
As David Cameron claimed, the Scottish independence debate...
...has been settled for a generation.